[Music]
all right do you guys know who the
rapper gunner is gonna gonna yeah
all right so gonna yeah i'm gonna gonna
had a pretty hot tip
for a lot of people all right yeah
pretty hot tip
he he uh he talked about how there's
this new crypto metaverse coming out
uh-oh and um he had he knows who's back
in the project and he knows this is
gonna fly and then he says in all caps
i'm taking this to the [ __ ] moon
join the telegram here oh i'm hyped
already for what's gonna happen and he's
got he's got a link to the telegram
group where you can go and get [ __ ]
hype about pushing uh p e which is what
it's called p e okay p e so he's pushing
pushing p pushing
all right that's the um that's the coin
that he's he's pushing you know what i'm
saying is there a m-e
no
there is but let's not get too crazy
there is um
and this is what happened to the coin
with over over the next couple hours
holy [ __ ] stomped yeah he basically
pumped and dumped what what's up pricing
uh so don't take financial advice from
ghana it looks like it hit let's see
does he have a dollar sign never got to
a penny it was always it was like yeah
tenths of a sec
so he basically just waited to pump his
product and he cashed out on his fans he
pumped it on his fans
then he dumped it and then he deleted
the tweet oh wow
wow right and do you think do you think
it's one of those things where it was
his thing or did he meet up with some
like crypto crew it's usually something
like that because he says he says you
know shane moon charge is back in the
project i know this is going to fly i'm
taking this to the moon and then yeah
eight hours later it drops 90 in value
he deletes the tweet he walks away do we
know how much you walk away with a
rugged we we don't yet
like what
what's everybody's [ __ ] sellout uh a
price
what do you mean so like if it hits if
my stack hits this much oh no like uh
same thing like your reputation right
like what's that worth it's like you can
pump something and then it's just kind
of like i'm down to like throw away
everything that i've worked on in my
reputation because the weird thing is
that that that equity is different for
like a [ __ ] rapper yeah like they're
not going to lose their fans off that
[ __ ]
guaranteed he's not yeah because some
people are like oh he's so gangster you
see what he did yeah it's like rug
pulled us
so cool
his next track is called rug pool
he's [ __ ] funny he's not like a
crypto influencer on youtube they did
that [ __ ] that's true
this is like totally different yeah
hip-hop people get away with so much
[ __ ] they do yeah somebody shot [ __ ]
meg the stallion in the foot and then
nothing happened there was a rapper that
shot lanes actually tory lanez is the
guy who ended up selling his [ __ ]
music uh uh on the blockchain and made
like a million bucks or something yeah
but he shot someone a single song
no there's something in there
like how many things has chris brown
been in yeah how many times has he beat
up a girl like more than once when it
comes to rappers it's it's almost like
it's expected to it's like even rock
stars
like you just do crazy [ __ ] you're
supposed to be punk rock you trash a
hotel everyone's like yo we know and
then you're like oh dee and your legacy
gets even better there's such a [ __ ]
invisible great pass for rap it's
amazing yeah because if a pop star did
this or someone else it's like what i
mean you can't even have a pop star put
a misogynist lyric yeah but then if you
look at the whole of rap come on imagine
if david swift was like i'm taking this
to the moon join the telegram here
that's like a total different scenario
man great there's a [ __ ] double
standard for sure
but isn't it because it's like um a lot
of it also has like gangsterisms to it
so it's like duff well what do you
expect like a
like this dude's like talking about the
streets and shooting and whatever it's
not like we're talking about will smith
here
you know
the myth the legend like if will smith
did this [ __ ] you know
invest in jiggy coins
he'd be on a red table and then he make
more money off of it in the next
autobiography yeah so something that's
about to happen and i want people to be
pretty aware of right is like we're
about to have the super bowl and like
there's already a bunch of ad campaigns
about crypto stuff
and you know
chances are if you're listening to a
celebrity talking about crypto stuff
they're just reading the copy they don't
know what the [ __ ] they're talking about
right there and this guy i promise you
he doesn't know what push and peace was
they what they did is they minted a [ __ ]
ton of coins right they they control
that supply bunch of people buy it they
run the price up and these guys dump it
on your heads and that's that's them
rugging right they're walking away with
the pile of money and then you're left
without any volume liquidity to sell to
so you're [ __ ] just holding bags
forever right so yeah that that's going
to happen with the super bowl wellness
[ __ ] just be careful out there man just
like
don't fall for [ __ ] twitter scams
like this like
even when it's from official people it's
like that's that's
they don't know what they're pushing
dude there's no like uh sec violation or
something that he did that people that
they can get them on oh i'm sure this is
fraud i'm sure that they'll come for him
in some way eventually yeah but
nothing's happened yet this just
happened this is also technically still
like the private sector right
so like there's like loopholes and and
just [ __ ] like you know what i mean
the judge is gonna go oh it's hip-hop
never mind oh yeah my bad i think it's
uh with jean renses oh [ __ ]
i think jay-z and
maybe i think it was meek mill or
working on a bill
that uh if it passes you can't use rap
lyrics in like a court of law or
something like that so if you're like in
your rap league you're like yeah i did
shoot that guy 12 times in the back or
whatever and it's like hella true or
something but you can't because it's not
i can understand that
performance art so why should bobby
schmurder didn't they understand i think
so they don't look at other genre songs
in the same way yeah like they don't
look at rock yeah in that same way where
it's like incriminating evidence if you
have doesn't really use those lyrics
right where you're talking about
murdering blasting somebody else yeah
they cited some sources where like oh
you don't look at johnny cash's [ __ ] and
like think that he actually did any of
that stuff well country they talk about
like [ __ ] drive tractors all day you
don't drive that many tractors
you're phony that's true
or even like [ __ ]
queen right or what is it like
mama i killed a man yeah jesus christ
yeah but that's different if [ __ ]
freddie mercury was being indicted for
murder and then you it actually matched
up
and the mom's like he did call me yeah
he didn't comment this is based off a
dream exactly i do recall that
conversation
yeah remember oj's i did it book yes if
i had a word to do or to do it
if i was guilty this is how i would have
been how i would have killed the court
the glove did fit let me pull up this
cover
yeah the cover is i did it and the if is
like inside of that little [ __ ] oh my
god so it's like
wow so
ridiculous damn that fool's gangster man
why's the noble clickbait
is he in jail or is he out he's out he's
out right for all the souvenir stuff
that's not such a crazy thing to do that
is pretty crazy because
i think uh in the future we might even
see court cases where they uh watch
vlogs and use it against influencers
crazy because you know it is it is a bit
of a performance art that we do but it's
a lot more realer than something like
uh music right or something like maybe
reality tv where there's a you know set
and the cast and everything's kind of
semi-scripted right so then what if like
there was a domestic abuse or some kind
of murder or something that went down
like the the that one girl the laundry
one or whatever potato
yeah and then um they can use evidence
in the vlog
against you know
you know the the the accused or whatever
that'll be [ __ ] that's where i think
it makes sense it's like if in a rap
song you put a clue and then using that
clue they found the [ __ ] murder
that's different than if they're like oh
you probably did it because you said you
did it like that's yeah kind of
different like don't put [ __ ] clues
yeah but you get you know with the fifth
amendment you can't incriminate yourself
just talking about something like
necessarily like just like like i'm
talking about like hey guys like yeah i
killed a guy one time like i'm doing
stan a bit and then they're like you're
going to [ __ ] prison bro
you know what i mean yeah yeah i can't
do that so at least there's at least
there's some
backing that already sounds like a
loophole
well i mean dude look at o.j
that's the best example i can think of
he actually wrote in detail about the
murders the way that they went down and
then all he has to hide behind is like
if and then he he also
you can't be tried for the same crime
twice and he was already ready right
yeah well that guy should tell the law
work so wow that's so crazy it's crazy
the law is perfect what about the edd
stuff you guys heard about that the
rappers that were rapping about how they
um fronted the edd
and they had
uh unemployment unemployment especially
during the pandemic so they were like
rapping about how they got other
people's etd or whatever they got edd
money or whatever and then they got
arrested i think i don't know whatever
happened let's see that's that's that's
the thing it's like they just rapped
about a clue exactly it's like if
they're gonna [ __ ] you can give
someone the idea to check on you that's
your fault because there's been some
like other like more like gangster
rappers and i think like the midwest my
buddy was telling me about the story but
i guess he killed somebody and then he
rapped about it immediately like a
raptor made a song about how i killed so
and so and then he got arrested dude
that's [ __ ] just being dumb yeah but
it's also self-expression too yeah you
gotta express yourself because after you
kill somebody you gotta talk about it
i gotta grow up on 245 main street la
california 9-1 whatever and then the
[ __ ] cops go and do a drug bust there
and then they're like that's your place
bro nah it's performance art i made that
place up that's that's the problem the
problem isn't uh isn't the law it's it's
a [ __ ] lack of symbolism yeah it's
like you guys got to know more
allegories and illusions
so [ __ ] literally buried this goes
back to your james blunt [ __ ]
yeah dude [ __ ] can't stand that guy like
too literally i might have offered
someone once
last year or not
i walked up to his face i shot him twice
maybe probably because then you just
sound like a key and peel sketch it's
not [ __ ] art
not that that's not art how would you
rewrite um i saw her face in a crowded
place
i mean maybe that is a [ __ ] murder
and he is the real [ __ ] guy james
bond has a bunch of bodies in the
basement yeah it's a crowded place with
all the [ __ ] bodies there you go i
saw your face then that's how you do it
he just cuts off people's faces you must
be an angel because you're dead
[Laughter]
see hip hop needs to be more like james
blunt yeah genius because he's actually
not blunt it's a blunt
oh
he's not literal he's not blind
it's irony
you